alphonse boudard tu as voté dimanche
dernier non non je veux pas là palois de
voter se dire que bientôt très bientôt
on va enseigner la littérature dans les
écoles ben oui c'était toujours pas
droit de voter c'est à dire que je
pourrais l'avoir parce que au bout d'une
dizaine d'années après on finisse sa
peine
si on a une bonne conduite alors j'ai
une bonne conduite puisque j'avais le
prix san boys en littérature que je
faisais des livres des films je pouvais
demander qu'on me réhabilite way
seulement dans la sphère ou gt gt avec
deux autres zèbres qui avait foutu le
camp
ai-je été oubliée obligé de payer leurs
frais de justice
et puis une partie civile alors j'ai
trouvé que ça faisait cher pour avoir le
droit de voter
mais tu as déclaré une fois de façon je
m'en fous je suis pas démocrate je suis
pas démocrate je m'en fous parce que je
pense que la loi de 95 conte sur cinq
mecs intelligence de m'intéresse pas
spécialement mais tu sais la rue en
médecine on l'a vu dans des tas de
domaines où des types se bat contre tout
le monde et c'est eux qui ont raison
alors il ya peut-être un parti de 3% qui
a raison sur tout le reste
peut-être c'est les écologiques ce que
j'ai réussi à voter écolo je sais que
c'est possible
en tout cas ils ont raison d'une
certaine façon alors pourquoi pas
c'était coupables de quoi au juste
bah j'ai été coupable deux fois deux
choses différentes étaient assez tout
terrain ouais
la première fois j'étais dans une
affaire de fausse monnaie c'est à dire
de fausse monnaie
c'était après la guerre il y avait des
billets américains émules dans l'armée
américaine dément
et soi-disant français ouais alors ça
m'a valu une relative indulgence parce
que je n'étais pas passibles des peines
de travaux forcés qui sont prévues quand
on sait la monnaie américaine oui
c'était pas de la monnaie française et
il y avait du tirage d'ailleurs entre le
gouvernement français et le gouvernement
américain dont c'était presque une bonne
action
donc on a et on a été condamné puis j'ai
bénéficié la lune amnistie concernant
spécialement les ligues résistants et
anciens combattants de leclerc ou de
taiwan à des coffres puis après après
j'étais dans une affaire de coffre otis
elle l'a été dans les 57 et je suis
sorti en 61 mettait jamais but et
personne
bah non je n'essaie jamais dû débuter
des gens peut être à la guerre comme ça
on est loin parce que c'est très c'est
très facile de but et les gens de très
loin alors un jour c'était au mitard à
freiner pitt a ressenti le besoin
d'écrire
j'étais allée du mal d'ailleurs écrivez
à califourchon sur un banc à côté des
chiottes louis fabriqué une petite lampe
le sillage de son leader au fils allait
commencer là je me suis dit qu'il y
avait donc mais qui s'était sorti de
cette affaire comme ça parce que les
rémois s'est elle quitte ou double
moment où je sors fait j'étais tübach en
plus ça pour un martyr et impôts long
et c'était pour plonger ouais je me
serais retrouvé ou bien dans une espèce
d'état peut être réussie de vagues
truands qui s'occupe d'une bois finalité
rae s'est tout de même pas très
roboratif way ou alors j'aurai fini
comme une cloche
j'aurais très mal fini j'étudie que
maintenant qu'est la télé dans les
prisons il ya plus personne qui peut
faire ça parce que s'ils avaient eu
dallas tu te région nous allons faire
tout ça non c'est à dire je sais pas si
j'aurais regardé dallas j'aurais essayé
d'être dans une saison est de regarder
un peu autre chose
enfin j'aurais été de toute façon
laisser emmerder x et comment ça s'est
passé à leur portée la réalité commenté
commenté arriver à faire parvenir le
ménage à lui inscrit à un éditeur gelé
tenter un truc avec un maton parachute
heures
donc il sort le manuscrit tu lui file du
pool femme dort file du pognon et puis
elle va chercher le manuscrit à tel
endroit on a tapé à la machine il s'est
baladé
il a été refusé celui là à plusieurs
endroits et quand je suis sorti j'avais
rien publier encore y avait ce manuscrit
qui se traînaient et puis j'ai déjà les
ans je suis sorti pour aller à l'hôpital
me faire opérer
ouais et comme s'il était en
dans cet hôpital marie lannelongue le
livre qui avaient circulé tout d'un coup
des gens sont venus me voir de chez plon
ouais c'est pourtant pas le style de la
maison plomb cette esthétique de la
mairie l'éditeur du général de gaulle
dans la maison ils y allaient à ce même
michel tournier et michel tournier
m'avait fait une bonne note de lecteurs
de lecture ton vrai nom c'est pas le
france godard non mais je le garde pour
les dames c'est michel de vrai prénom
alors maintenant à bien tu cesses ouais
c'est comment le vrai nom je lis parfois
tu veux pas le dire c'est bon tu raconte
des trucs c'est à dire je te dire
pourquoi je payerai qua non est ce que
j'ai de la famille
ouais c'est des enfants etc alors je le
perds les emmerder avec ça a mis
d'accord sur un côté enfant oui on vrai
nom est fortement web là il ya un truc
aussi tutu raconté beaucoup de choses
très très privé sur ta vie sur cette
époque mettait jamais voulu parler de ta
mère comment ça se fait parce que je le
ferais peut-être un peu plus tard que
c'est quelque chose de plus délicat le
lien je vois dans ces milieux
de mes lettres les mets qui s'allonge
très vite il rassemble beaucoup moins
avec une extrême impudeur je suis pas un
public
tu prend du bon temps alors oui c'est sa
place unique elle venait de temps en
temps la maison était voilà tu t'arrêtes
j'ai rencontré ça si je suis si je sais
pas les lieux de vie où je suis passé le
micro vous voyez un bouquin qui sort de
daniel costelle et de toi tu vas les
interviews que je fais avec lui ça mène
ma vie pleine de trous se dire quoi me
les plaines de trop c'est à dire qu'ils
parlent des trous qui a eu avec la tôle
et puis avec ces histoires de
tuberculose qu'on avait les éponges
bufeo me salir les époux vont quêter
bouffer cuttat par les bassines alcott
qui faisait des trous et d'ailleurs
quand on regardait une radio de tubas on
voyait des trous mais t on avait rappelé
à des patates dépêche que tu as fait un
bouquin génial s'appelle l'hôpital
l'hôpital j'ai fait ça j'ai récupéré
tout un moment donné j'ai vécu un
certain nombre de toutes choses qui ont
été dur à vivre
et puis quand je me suis mis à écrire
j'ai fait de la récupération content
mais il ya un légionnaire qui boit le
l'alcool dans lequel on nettoie les
thermomètres commune et qui meurt le
coût des moeurs qu il meurt tout de
suite
ouais ouais l'alcool akaichi ouvriers
toyer les thermomètres il se lève
péniblement ils avaient déjà les deux
planches on mettait deux planches au lit
en
demain qui va soulever celui-là il va
s'effondrer
on était là on le voit se lever moi de
prendre garde mais qu'est ce qui la fout
il a le courage d'un coup ce dernier
courage de se lever il va boire un coup
et on y voit la première chose qui lui
arrive et qui claquent
il se défonce à on voit le la puissance
du vice ouais tamise le point commun de
ce cas mais c'était une pure et quand
tout d'un coup t'as plus rien et tu n'as
que ça tu te lèves et toutes tes forces
vers l'alcool et poivre ou par exemple
justement on parle de ça tu les fous
dans des coins impossible dans le désert
une écoute toi avec un livre on avec
même une baisse et comme les défenses
exactement comment tu vis maintenant tu
as fait blinde et apporte avec l'argent
du renaudot
non j'ai fait une fois bien et me dire
pourquoi j'ai fait plein débat porte
parce que tu faiblard et apporte pour
contre les petits corps seraient le
métier bien pourtant levé il enlève la
télévision il enlève une paire de
jumelles et quand je lis ça fait chier
ici sur le tapis
si c'est des vrais dit la porte blindée
ils en ont rien à [ __ ] il est là le
louvre elle est vrai bien de pas chez
toi parce qu'ils savent très bien que
t'as pas de pognon qui les intéresse
c'est d'ailleurs un endroit où il ya
comme ouvrir alors plus ça va plus c'est
difficile ce métier il ya beaucoup de
cas les gens ils ont des coffres à
l'abri long des débats luchonnais faut
déjà des équipes tout à fait
extraordinaire comme celle de spaggiari
espère tous les coffres parce que sinon
on sait bien maintenant que dans le
large en tout venant d'une petite bande
qui est l'équipe qui font des braquages
pour vibrer et alors ils sont quatre là
dessus tu vois ce que ça donne c'est le
salaire d'un cadre supérieur point final
fut qu ils ont recommencé le mois
d'après voilà c'est quand tu l'as fait
six fois la septième du temps long et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu